fact the eSports role is just like the
Wild West but without the pistols horses
and syphilis fact without regulation
eSports players could die well some
players aren't getting paid but I don't
think anyone's actually dying okay fine
but eSports needs a competent
commissioner someone wouldn't suspend a
player for something as stupid is the
inflation pressure of their Falls huh
you want a commissioner no sports and
video games check someone who's high
school mascot is a mythical creature dog
Ervin's someone who's punted a football
in sub-zero weather this guy someone
who's not afraid to jungle or take that
last support role Oh God astron in
someone who will do whatever it takes to
ensure equality and regulation in
eSports I'm Chris Kluwe and eSports
needs a champion someone who can lead
and protect the integrity of
professional video game someone who can
regulate the rage quitters and tackle
the trolls someone like me so let's
unify the team's game developers and
various organizations and named me
eSports commissioner because I'd kick
acid vote Chris Kluwe for eSports
commissioner because he'd kick ass at it
I'm Chris clue and I approve this
message I think
you